okay so then why did he quote Psalm 82
is it not written in your law I say you
are Gods let me now show you are you
ready guys you have to pay attention or
you're not going to learn honestly this
is for you I've done articles sessions
on this but I'm doing it to protect you
by the power of the Holy Spirit and
refute their lies and shame these
blasphemers now here's the psalm that he
quoted Psalm 826 and you're going to see
what his point is when we quote the
psalm in context I said you are gods and
all of you are children of the most high
but here's what they did not mention
because Jesus is quoting a Psalm to Jews
who know the context so the Lord knows
that when he mentions this verse the
Jews would identify the context and know
who these gods were so who are they now
notice what it says about these Gods
verse seven but you shall die like Adam
you who I called Gods sons of the most
high you will die like Adam did like any
man and fall like one of the princes so
whoever these gods are these are Gods
who are coming under the Wrath and
condemnation and Judgment of God because
God will punish them by death he will
strike them dead and he will cause them
to fall from favor why why is he
striking them dead why is he punishing
them by condemning them to death let's
see are we ready now for the
context let's read that was six and
seven but let's read verses 1 to 5 you
ready
are you ready for the context okay God
stands in the congregation of the mighty
he judges among the gods now let's break
this I'm going to give you the Hebrew
Elohim
God
okay God watch here Psalm 821 Elohim the
Hebrew word is Elohim God
stands in the assembly in the Assembly
of God e so I'm writing it out this is a
word for God singular
of so Elohim stands in the Assembly of e
right to judge the
Elohim
Gods okay follow with me so here you
have the Elohim who's in the Heavenly
Council of e e singular for God this is
his Council and here's this Elohim who's
in the council to condemn the other
Elohim that dwell in that Council okay
are you with me so far so here it's
referring to Elohim taking his stand in
the Assembly of e okay God to judge the
Elohim the
gods so why is God judging these Gods
let's read verse two how long he's
talking out to the gods will you judge
unjustly see they're unjust rulers and
show partiality to the wicked who favor
the wicked and help the wicked Prosper
like Biden and Putin sah now they're
being commanded defend the poor and the
fatherless don't help the
wicked do justice to The Afflicted and
needy help those who are oppressed
against their oppressors deliver the
poor
needy free them from the hand of the
wicked now notice what it says about
these gods they do not know nor do they
understand they walk about in darkness
all the foundation of the Earth are in
St
so the reason why these gods are being
condemned because they're evil rulers
Wicked rulers who do not help the poor
the needy the orphan the Widow the
oppressed they actually help and
embolden the Wicked the Tyrant the
oppressor the greedy to prosper at the
expense of the poor the Widow the orphan
and God says because you gods are wicked
and you're doing it now I'm going to
destroy you and you will no longer rule
the Earth
you with me
there you guys got it so
far okay so what's the point these are
evil Wicked rulers I didn't say they
were not Angels I'm just saying rulers
because there's a debate we're not going
to get into the debate these are evil
Wicked
rulers who instead of helping the poor
the Widow the orphan the
oppressed and rebuking and punishing and
condemning the Wicked the Tyrant the
rich the greedy they're helping the
wicked to prosper at the expense of the
poor and the righteous so God says I'm
fed up with you rulers now I'm going to
arise to condemn you to death I'm G to
remove you from the earth and I will
reign over the
Earth okay everyone got
it okay now now you're going to
understand Jesus's point are you now
ready to understand what Jesus's point
is are you ready to understand what
Jesus's point
is now let's begin focus on the fact we
can all agree they're rulers who were
given authority to rule the Earth but
they corrupted the Earth so what is
Jesus's point he's saying to the Jews
you Hypocrites don't you acknowledge the
psalm as part of the law inspired
scripture
yes can the psalm be falsified proven
wrong no that would be blasphemy that's
why it says the word of God cannot be
broken if this is God's word it's
reliable it's trustworthy it's inspired
it cannot be mistaken well if the psalm
calls Wicked evil rulers gods and you
wouldn't dare accuse the psalmist the
blasphemy how dare you then accuse me of
blasphemy when I'm the Son of God who
does what God does unlike these rulers
who are evil condemned by God so if evil
rulers can be called gods and his sons
and you don't accuse the psalmist of
blasphemy for calling them gods and the
sons of the most high how dare you
accuse me of blasphemy when I'm doing
the very works of God to prove that the
father is authorizing my statements and
my actions because I'm one with him you
Hypocrites that's what he's
doing you understand what he's doing
now can everyone with me do you
understand what he's saying he's saying
is it not written your law and you know
the laws from God and the law is perfect
cannot be falsified and you cannot
accuse the LA of blasphemy so if the law
called these evil Wicked rulers who God
is going to condemn to death gods and
the sons of the most high and you would
not dare accuse the psalmist of
blasphemy for calling them such how dare
you slander and falsely accuse me of
blasphemy for saying I'm God's son who
does everything that the father does as
proof that the father is in me and I the
father and that he's authorizing and
approving of my statements and deeds how
dare you accuse me of blasphemy that's
why when we finish it now looks like in
John 103738 now watch
here John 103738 after he just finished
saying that if I do not do the works of
my father do not leave me but if I do if
I'm doing the works that the father
wants me to do that has authorized me to
do in Union with the father though you
do not believe me believe the works that
you may know and believe that the father
is in me and I in him now watch your
reaction therefore they sought again to
seize him but he escaped out of their
hand see what they didn't read when
Jesus finishes the point they understood
all the more he was claiming to be God
because now they want to kill him even
more here it is John 1039 after he said
look right after he quotes it 37 and 39
if I do not do the works of my father do
not believe me but if I do though you do
not believe me believe the works let the
works prove to you the father has
authorized my mission to say what I say
and do what I do because he's one with
me and I'm one with him right that you
may know and believe that the father's
in me meaning in Union with me in
fellowship with me in agreement with me
and I in him what is their reaction oh
yeah okay yeah you know you're right we
must therefore they sought again to
seize him but he escaped out of their
hand so they actually understood that he
was indeed reinforcing his claim of
being a man who is God though not the
father so Jesus wasn't denying the claim
that he is a man making himself out to
be God he was denying the claim that
he's blaspheming for making that claim
see what these Muhammad and stolickers
did see what they
did but I got more from John 10 I'm not
done
yet I'm not done yet did you understand
now what Jesus was doing if Wicked evil
rulers can be called Gods the sons of
God even though God condemns them to
death how dare you accuse me of
blasphemy when I'm doing the works of my
father as miraculous Divine proof the
father's in Union with me working with
me and I'm in him working with him and
he's authorizing and affirming my deeds
and
statements so when Jesus finished his
point they understood all the more yeah
he is claiming to be God even though
he's man but we're not convinced that
he's not
blaspheming so did everyone understand
Jesus's real point before I move
on because now we got more meat oh
that's not not we're not done
yet we're not done yet because now
you're going to see who Jesus is in
respect to that Psalm in Psalm
82 who Jesus is in respect to that Psalm
if you're getting it all right let's now
let me read 82 the god these God death
who ruled the world corruptly unjustly
look what it says in verse eight arise
oh God judge the Earth you God who's
going to condemn these Wicked rulers for
corrupting the Earth condemn them to
death and take back the Earth as your
possession arise oh God judge the Earth
for you shall inherit All Nations so now
here's where you really need to be pay
attention coko and everyone else really
pay
attention really focus and ask Holy
Spirit help you to focus the god who's
going to condemn these Gods to death is
a God who judges the Earth and inherits
the Nations as his possession so he's
going to take back the nations from
their rulership and he's going to Reign
Over the nations in righteousness and
Justice and mercy and love
okay arise oh God judge the Earth for
you shall inherit all the nations now
here's where you're going to get blown
away the God who condemns these Gods to
death is The God Who judges the Earth
watch here get ready get to get blown
away John
522 to 23 John
522-23 okay watch here the God who
condemns these gods and inherits the
Earth is The God Who
judges the Earth John 52223 listen
guys for the father judges no one
but has committed all judgment to the
son the father will not come to judge he
will send me to judge
everyone why that all should honor the
son just as they honor the father he who
does not honor the son does not honor
the father who sent him John 52223 our
Lord just said and thank maram for
posting our Lord just said I am the one
who comes to judge the earth I the one
who comes to judge mankind I'm the one
who will judge the world and its
inhabitants my father won't be doing the
judging judging he authorized me to come
and judge and that's confirmed in Acts
1730 31 as well why because my father
wants everyone to realize and know who I
am I am the son who is worthy of the
same honor that my father receives and
my father wants everyone to honor me the
way they honor him if you don't give me
the honor you give to the father you
stand condemned so wait the God who
condemns the god
Gods is The God Who judges the Earth and
inherits the
Nations and yet Jesus says I'm the one
who comes to judge the
Nations Mankind and then in Matthew 28
18 and 19 Jesus then says all authority
in Heaven and Earth has been given to me
therefore go and make Make Disciples of
all Nations wait wait wait wait
Jesus the entire creation is now yours
and and all the nations belong to you
and must be your disciples whereas in
Psalm 82 it says God arises to judge the
Earth and inherit the Nations so you're
saying you're the God who inherits the
Nations as your possession and you're
The God Who arises to judge the Earth
you're that
God that's who you just claimed to
be so far with me cuz I'm not done yet
oh I got more
wait hey we got more
hey yep Genesis 18:25 Persona Chris it's
Genesis 18:25 shall not the judge of all
the Earth do what is right and that's
Jehovah appearing as a man okay did you
guys get it I can't move on if you
didn't get it who is the god of Psalm
828 who judges the Earth inherits the
Nations Jesus said I am that God because
all authority in Heaven and Earth has
been given to me
all creation is subject to me all
creation belongs to me I'm Sovereign
Over All Creations so now all nations
must become my disciples Matthew 2818
to19 and John 5:22 the father judges no
one but is entrusted all judgment to the
son okay did you get it now before I
move on to another Point that's going to
blow you away oh that's nothing
yet exactly
Paul now watch what Jesus Jus said about
the gods let's see hold on let's see if
you caught it John 10: 34:36 now please
may the Holy Spirit illuminate you
listen Jesus answered them is it not
written in your law I said you are Gods
now watch if he called them Gods to whom
the word of God came and the scripture
cannot be broken notice the word of God
came to these gods in condemnation
notice what he
saying the word of God came to these
Gods what word word of condemnation cuz
Psalm 82 is condemning them right you
catch it it's condemning them these are
the gods to whom the word of God came to
condemn these are the gods to whom the
word of God came to condemn you you see
what Jesus just
said okay but I don't think you caught
it these are the gods to whom the word
of God came to condemn who came to
condemn them the word of God but wait
John 1:1 says in the beginning was the
word and the Word was with God and the
Word was God and the word became flesh
so Jesus just told you the word that
came to them to condemn
them is none other than that very word
who's now flesh speaking to those
corrupt Jews those corrupt rulers and
condemning
them you see how deep it
is the word of God came in condemnation
of these Gods but who are you Jesus well
John told you I am I am the word of God
who came into the
world to judge those who do not believe
and save those who will in other words
Jesus just told you if you're paying
attention to the gospel who he is I'm
not one of them I am that very word who
comes from God to condemn evil rulers
who refuse to do what is right in my
[Music]
sight that's why Jesus said that I the
one whom the father Sanctified and sent
into the world John 10:36 do you say of
him whom the father Sanctified and sent
into the
world he blasphemes because I said I the
Son of God in other words I'm the word
that comes from God into the world to
save those who believe and pass Jud
judement and those who
won't John 9 39-41 watch John 9 39-
41 here 9 39 to
41 here it is chapter before and Jesus
said for judgment I have come into this
world that those who do not see may see
and th that and that those who see may
be made blind now some of the Pharisees
notice rulers Psalm 82 the word of God
came to those rulers to condemn them for
their wickedness and here's Jesus the
son of God whom the father Sanctified
and sent into the world to condemn these
rulers for not recognizing the word who
became flesh then some of the Pharisees
who were with him heard these words and
said to him are we blind also Jesus said
to them if you are blind you would have
no sin but now you say we see Therefore
your sin
remains did you catch it now notice how
Jesus used their words against them oh
so you claim that you see so you deny
your blind therefore you have no excuse
for not recognizing whom I am I'm going
to use your words against you so you say
you see huh you're not blind therefore
you have no exuse not to see clearly who
I am therefore by rejecting me you are
now fully responsible because you
realize who I am and still reject me so
you remain in your sin
okay do we understand now the context or
no you understand what Jesus was not
doing he was not saying the Jews are
wrong for thinking I'm a man making
myself out to be God he just claimed to
be God by doing things only Jehovah can
do he was saying you are wrong and
thinking I am blaspheming for making
myself out to be God one with the father
though I
man you see
it's ironic that it's the Muslims who
take the side of these unbelieving Jews
and condemning us for saying this man
Jesus is God in other words these
unbelieving Jews and the Muslims and
their Prophet are of the same Spirit the
devil because like the Jews condemn
Jesus for claiming to be God because
they thought he was just a man the
Muslims condemn us for blasphemy because
we see Jesus as more than a man but God
In the Flesh
everyone got it Coco everyone else you
got it now